the the women who have that are married
but who have that mindset if they had
the mindset of where their priority
because here's the thing if your
priority when you're younger right is to
have a family if that's your priority
most women who have that protein that
young they get married that young and
they have that now yeah I think what
happens is and you know it's just the
way it is in the modern era
more women are choosing to prioritize
their career in their 20s well not only
that but yes women who are bitter who
didn't advise younger girls to follow
along the same path as them so you'll
get the single mothers women that have
been [ __ ] over by men because of the
wrong decisions that they've made in
topic as they go for and then when they
when they talk to younger women they say
oh you know live your life just go out
there sleep around and when you get
older you'll find the right guy I've
never gotten that advice ever I listen
so the way I have I no because older
older girls like lie to you oh wow yeah
but also like again that's just like so
toxic like you're acting out of your
trauma you know that what do you mean
acting out of your trauma so okay
okay
um but like acting out your trauma is
basically like okay so say you went
through something bad right like I don't
know you got with someone and you had a
kid with them and and they left you
right and then you then usually women
leave but yeah yeah okay cool in this
scenario the met the man left
um unless say
then that person then tells their
daughter just go out do what you want
blah blah don't get a man blah blah
right that's acting out of your trauma
because something bad happened to you
and because of that bad experience that
has now shaped your advice it's okay do
you hear how you like tell that story
though it's like something bad happened
to you instead of I made that decision
like for some reason with women whenever
we tell stories like it's we always take
the accountability off of us
hmm
you guys talk what is your submission
cost yeah
um
I would say
um
he can earn a little bit less than I
earn now because of like it will be less
responsibility on here it will be less
pressure because this is going to be a
two-person household I feel like right
now I earn over 100k
and that's because it's just me by
myself I have to sustain it like like
two people so if he earned for like
let's say 80 or something and I'm
managing the household that's fine so it
was the question not that we had to we
weren't working anymore right she never
but she never specified no no submission
so the reason I use that question is
like you trust him enough that if he
said that yeah yeah so you won't be
working anymore yeah yeah but no but
attaining the household but I have the
pressure of that like the point isn't
that you would like quit your job before
the income though the point is like do
you trust him enough to make that
decision oh even if maybe you disagreed
like maybe he wants to move to the
country and like go down into housing I
don't know what he's saying I always say
something that
um you see us women we talk especially
when we're single we always talk like
but once emissions come in a guy can be
a 15K and he tells us to leave
we could but this is the bad thing yeah
and that's that's just about to say that
these are part of the issues that we
have we don't think logically we always
think with our emotions is good
well I swear at the last show we talked
about leadership and I think someone
brought the fact that you know women can
be effective leaders and everybody's
like no I said I don't think I said that
um I don't know if I said did I think on
the live show that I said that um I feel
like the issue is women don't know the
power that they have don't yeah I said
they don't know the power they have they
try to play the powers that they think
they need to have because they see it
glamorized so men in higher positions
and everything yeah and the thing with
us women is sometimes we're very greedy
we want a bit of everything right so we
see there being you see we see men being
glorified in that area we too we want to
go there
feminists we too want to go there and be
part of that party whereas we're being
glor we're being glorified here if we
were to embrace that position we don't
realize the power we have that's why
they always say behind every successful
man is a successful woman we don't
always need to be that's a feminist
probably you think Genghis Khan had a
successful
but being being successful doesn't mean
having status being being it was a
successful woman a good woman sorry but
we don't have to we can we we have an
issue with not being in the Limelight
now so I can say that background yeah
there's nothing wrong with us being in
the background Robin he's back when no
one's there and him going out I don't
know why women don't get Thrills out of
just knowing that I think it's the lack
of appreciation I feel like uh someone
said I don't know yeah appreciation in
terms of like when we don't feel like
okay babe thank you for doing that or
thank you being appreciated for the
little things after a while we now want
to fight to get noticed it's just just
to revolve that do you do do we women
say thank you for going out to work
that's fine thank you for making the
money thank you for giving me the money
to buy food 100 we do not everybody
I think we're only learning these praise
I'm in now I don't think men are praised
I think all of that is an expectation
good morning no more I think all of them
and so it's like it's like we want a top
20 income 30 income but are you top 20
30 in women the reason why well I kind
of speak for myself the reason why I
want that right yeah because I I am that
yeah financially right but that's that's
what women do when they become the the
men that they want to marry
you could say you could say that I am
that and I want that and I understand
but like for me like I do pretty well
this with this show I would never in my
right mind expect a guy that I date to
make as much like it just wouldn't make
sense but like I said with me okay so
imagine if I was on like 300K and a guy
was on 200k for me that's not a problem
because we can still live a certain
quality of life quality of life
you hit the nail on the head this is the
problem like this is the issue is that
women won't go down in lifestyle for a
family
and for peace and happiness because and
like they want to stay at that lifestyle
but it's like you know would you give up
getting your nails done get it like all
the things getting your nails done and
stuff isn't that's not the lifestyle a
smaller apartment a small like like less
of everything for a family for a family
and even you know quitting your job
letting him be the breadwinner for a
family
like Chris Rock made that joke you guys
men can't go back because sexually and
women can't go backwards in lifestyle so
like as women it's just like yo remember
when you're a teen and you dated the
first guy you dated you had a car and he
could you could pick you up take you out
wherever when that when that ended
you're like yeah I don't [ __ ] with guys
who don't have a car anymore yeah yeah
not only [ __ ] good guys who ever come
and then that proves Maxi's point about
10 sleeping with threes what do you mean
because when you've slept with a black
life but she wasn't a three though no I
think I was just saying about lifestyle
about what a man can do but this is why
I said girls adds to women's entitlement
because when you give them that
lifestyle the next guy they're expecting
that right they could have earned the
lifestyle oh yeah as many of you know I
was just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible